trae young with a postseason career high
18
assists tonight that makes him the
youngest player in nba postseason
history with at least
25 points and 15 assists in a playoff
game
younger than even chris paul was back in
2008 chris paul incidentally might also
be the oldest player ever with a 25
point
15 assist playoff game i don't know that
for a fact but
you know he's still productive at 36.
let's get to
trae young after the hawks win tall mike
yeah
hey trey um hey trey
um so i saw a little athletic tape on
your
shoulder can you just kind of walk me
through what's going on with your your
right shoulder
yeah uh i got a hit last game and it's
been kind of sore
he's got got a little bit sore over the
past couple of days
uh nate nate just hit me said y'all
asked me about it too and uh
i thought i'm gonna tell nobody anyways
um
because i was a big idiot so it was just
just a little source
um could you could you feel it affect
you at all at the
at the start of the game it seemed like
you got off to maybe a little bit of a
slower start like was it was it
bothering you
uh it was just kind of for me not it
wasn't a bother it was just kind of
fighting through it um
knowing knowing it was kind of sore just
trying to work it out keep it warm
throughout the game
um that's really pretty much what it was
i
i mean i'm not not blaming my [ __ ] on my
arm
i feel like i had a lot of good looks
and i just
just weren't going in and i got i got to
be better at knocking down my shots
next question from chris kershner
hey trey obviously in the first half you
guys were down by 18 at one point
uh what can you say about the resilience
from the squad
yeah i mean we've been fighting i mean
all year
we've been fighting all year and this
team never gives up
we no matter what the score is
throughout the game we know it's a long
game
the nba is a long game and uh 48 minute
game and for us we just
stay level headed throughout the whole
game every team's going to make runs and
so for us we just
i love the way we fight and uh i'm proud
of part of our team tonight
zach clone that's right this team shot a
little over 30 percent for the game as
you mentioned down 18.
how'd you win this our defense our
defense i mean you don't
you don't shoot that bad and shoot that
poorly and and still win the game if you
don't play good defense
and uh you played really good defense
and we took care of the ball
only four turnovers um and the big time
for us and
i think that's a big reason why we won
because i mean
even though we we shot 30 percent um in
both categories
we had over 100 possessions and
that's big for us we got a lot of a lot
of guys who can make plays so when you
have that many possessions
um and keep keep the ball on your side
and at least get up a shot
it's going to work out more times than
not
steve hummer yeah trey so what is uh
what is nate's reaction when you take
off your warm up and he sees your
your shoulder taped up yeah yeah he kind
of gave me a look like like
he was you know he didn't know about it
but i mean
i told him we're fine we're good we
let's go play let's go win
so well the fact that you uh you played
so well down the stretch that indicated
all that it was loosening up or
yeah i mean i i was it's all off
adrenaline at that point i'll probably
feel it i'm feeling it a little bit more
right now and
i'll probably feel a little bit more
tomorrow but i'm continuing to get
treatment on it and stuff like that so
uh but in the game in the moment um
i didn't feel it is it a bruise or a or
well how would you how would you
classify it uh i don't know it's not a
bruise on the outside it may be
on the inside it's just sore uh i don't
know
i don't know to really explain it to you
thanks
terrell thomas trey uh 18 assists for
you tonight
did you feel like the uh show during the
in the beginning of the game forced you
to be more of a facilitator or were you
just kind of going with the flow and the
pace of the game
yeah like like i do every game i just
read what what the defense is giving me
and uh they're doing a lot of hedging
and trapping and
um i mean for me that's that's fine and
it's good
it's now it's all about making the the
right play and
the open pass and uh so that's really
pretty much
what they did they were just forcing me
to um
really pretty much give up the ball
thank you my plane backsleep
hey trey uh john collins came out in the
second half and just kind of flipped a
switch on both ends you know you both
were getting the crowd involved enjoying
the moment you know how much does this
play affect you and the rest of the team
when he's in that zone yeah i mean it
affects us all
just like a long three can affect affect
our team in a positive way and get the
crowd going and get our team going
jc's dunks and has put bad dunks um are
the same way
they're infectious um the way i mean he
plays and his energy
uh it's big time for us so we're gonna
need him to continue to bring that
energy on both ends and
i'm happy with the way he played tonight
he big reason why we won tonight
and he's kind of going off the crowd you
know how how
how does tonight compare to other crowds
you know whether in college or high
school or other pro events you've been
in you know just
the environment tonight yeah i mean it's
tonight
this playoff environment has been a lot
different than
even since i've been here um it's been
great the fans been loud
been cheering i mean last game we didn't
give them too much of a reason to really
cheer but i mean all the other games
it's uh
it's been it's been great and they've
been they've been very supportive of us
and
really really pushing us over that edge
to give us that momentum that we need to
take care of home and that's what we
need to continue to do
hey trey congrats on the win um anyaka
he had about uh four points i think and
three rebounds and two blocks and he
played like
close to six and a half minutes what has
it been like to see
the rookie kind of get that kind of flow
going and even in
just that limited play time what has it
been like yeah it's big time
it's big time for us and i know
he's he wants to play more and things
like that and
i think lou has been a great great
addition to that lineup for him and
really really took over that mentor um
and really telling him where to go
telling him where he needs to be on both
ends uh
it's it's great oh it's so young and
he's like he's out there just wanting to
do perfect and
make the right plays and sometimes he'll
just be out of spots just because he
just doesn't know yet
and lou does a great job of really
helping him out and he
you can tell there's been a big
difference in in
the way he's played since his lose got
here so i'm happy with the way he's been
going
we'll go last two first from christos
and then from brandon harper
hey congratulations on the win the
performance is this win
can uh can this win change the whole
momentum of that series from your
perspective
and how confident you are about being
fired yeah i mean any anyone can change
momentum and
any win can uh can spark a team's energy
and
really get a team going so hopefully
this really
gives us a little bit more momentum and
and more uh i mean guys are ready ready
to go in
to philly and take care of business
brandon yeah trey uh great winning night
i know joelle is gonna do joelle things
and
you know in that second half you all
kind of flustered him a little bit he
was looking for foul calls
how do you kind of you know take the
momentum of you know attacking him in
that second half and bottle it up and
take it up to philadelphia
with you so you can maintain that
momentum in trying to
kind of you know keep him off balance
especially in that second half
yeah i mean like um like with any great
players
you're never going to be able to really
stop them and tonight
what clint did and what our team did but
mainly clint
what he did on that end was great just
showing his hands and you know
joe's i mean really good at drawing
fouls and getting guys in down trouble
so
making sure he was on the court being
able to play and staying out of foul
trouble was big for us
and um i mean
hopefully hopefully we get uh get that
same type of effort and um
i mean same same type of energy going
into game five against him because i
mean obviously he's gonna play a lot
harder and a lot better at home so we
got
we gotta be ready to for joel and the
rest of the team
in game five